[Music]
so before we go ahead and get started
with this video I'm just gonna put this
out there this is a sponsored video we
don't do any of that sneaky hit and [ __ ]
on this channel
we're straightforward we're honest
people here this video was sponsored by
East meet East the number one Asian
dating app in the United States and
other english-speaking countries and
just to put it out there
I'm not Tooting my own dick that's not a
saying I'm not Tooting my own boot not
[ __ ] it I do to my scoop let's see
that's what I do to my scoop I ain't
tootin my scoop but since I joined about
a year ago the user number tripled she
and that light just fell right there I
scared the [ __ ] out me are you crazy
you know since the last time I posted a
video about this I had some very
interesting responses I mean most of it
was really good but one person I'm not
gonna really name who cuz I don't really
remember who you are but if I did I
would blast the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of you
right now that's not a suspect but I
specifically remember somebody saying
well I'm just gonna wait till after I'm
done being busy with school and all this
other [ __ ] to go ahead and day so I have
more free time lookie here stupid online
dating is like perfect for people who
yes who don't really have free time so
this demographic is you and let me
explain why now for a lot of people out
there you guys don't realize how lucky
you are to have this [ __ ] back in the
day there was no such thing as online
dating there were some real [ __ ] you
actually would have to walk up to a
physical individual you're so good to
finally meet you
okay and if you look busted or they
didn't like you they would simply say
this hey yeah but with online dating you
can deceive people by having a really
high ankle picture safe [ __ ] hot you
won't even know I'm [ __ ] with you
what I'm saying is like online dating is
a God said now I'm with a girl right now
so I can't really experience the joys of
getting to meet random people with no
strings attached and simply seeing a
profile having every single thing that
you like already laid out for you you're
just sitting there waiting for somebody
to be prince charming or or princess
princess [ __ ] [ __ ] but those type of
opportunities are something that you get
when you actually go out there and you
pursue it right as my girlfriend I just
texted I told about I appreciated her
because we went on this trip together
she was like okay thank you for
appreciating me hopefully she gonna give
me something let's say you do try online
dating right and I'm telling you all
these great things about it and your
first date was a [ __ ] disaster well
guess what that's the risk that you're
gonna take and that's what's supposed to
happen the great thing about dating is
and I said this before the last video is
that you get to figure out what you want
by having these dates because you're
gonna find yourself in situations that
are very uncomfortable and you will tell
yourself hey now I know the signs of
what makes an uncomfortable date and
what I don't want to see in somebody so
I could just bounce the [ __ ] out you
have to be an uncomfortable situation
sometimes and put yourself out there to
be vulnerable for you to learn what you
want I'll tell you this about Muriel
Muriel did not even think about dating a
Korean guy get all these like negative
thoughts from her past experiences and
on top of that she didn't think she was
gonna date a fat Korean guy well guess
what baby I'm both of a man you love me
you ain't going nowhere
i deceived you hocus-pocus some of you
people at the end of the day you guys
have to learn how to take risk and just
say sometimes you know what it's okay if
I get hurt it's okay if I approach a
woman or a person and they say you know
what dude
you look like Kim jong-un's [ __ ] [ __ ]
you just gotta know that's just the
motions of life man dating is fun dating
is a time for you to explore and if you
can do that [ __ ] with the huge network
that doesn't just include the people
that you know in your random and instant
vicinity why not did I save insanity I'm
in vicinity whoa this is a sponsored
video but I'm passionate about this [ __ ]
she's real like my double chin
once again y'all this is a video
sponsored by east meet East that's East
meet East nutmeats but they were once
again gracious enough to hit me up after
we had such a good response last time to
get your asses out there to start dating
so remember the website is right here at
the end card and in the description box
below go ahead and check that out we
find the fun and [ __ ] out of everything
blogs by the way are literally anything
and everything now if you notice like
carpool confession and everything else
is all a part of this just stay tuned
for when these videos are going to come
out you do that by subscribing and
waiting for the notifications I love you
I will send you nudes and most likely
you're going to send them back ah
and you will say you'll subscribe to me
so I don't send you any more nudes